so you're not on the voice anymore this
is the first time in ten years that
you're you're here not talking about
being on the voice and is it something
you miss or how do you feel Adam Levine
opening up about his choice to leave the
voice for pretty much the first time on
Mondays Alan you know I miss I really do
miss it I love the people that I met and
worked with and obviously we all know
how I feel about Blake yeah that guy and
you know I do miss it but I also don't
miss how much I had to work you know I
was just constantly working for so many
years very lucky very fortunate very
blessed and all that but you know just
to be able to kind of stop it in this
moment to spend time with my my new
young family and yep and just how did
the greatest time ever now I'm just like
a stay-at-home dad I just stay home and
do very little
Adam abruptly exited a singing
competition show in May just after the
sixteenth season wrapped NBC had already
announced that he'd be back for season
17 so the move was pretty shocking but
now we know it was all for family those
babies are so precious I'm obsessed with
them I mean I know that's a good thing
because they're my children yes like I
really just I wanna hats why I don't do
much as I love tank I mean like I
genuinely just like adore them in a way
that I never knew I could adore any
little it's really sweet Adams wife
Behati Prinsloo shared the same
sentiment on the Today Show back in June
well I guess the good news is Adam is
off the voice down here so it'll be home
yeah he's on tour at the moment and he's
excited to get home and for the first
time has nothing to do I'm like what am
I
of course Gwen Stefani stepped in to
take Adams place on the voice but his
fellow judges still miss him yeah we're
sad to see him go we are very sad and
he's been a part of the show since it
began 16 seasons
has been so important to the show even
existing and so we're all going to miss
some it's weird not having Adam but it
is interesting the dynamic weird
literally all four different genres like
yeah and it's kind of interesting the
dynamic of that on the show you know
with Adam being gone I'm a lot I was
scary it's weird without him here it's
it's literally shocking to not have him
here Adams not on the show and and but I
want him to know that he can still kiss
my ass the bromance lives on show or not
stick with et for all the latest on the
voice I'm Katy Krause and I'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Applause]